>> Greg: WONDERFUL!
[LAUGHS]
OH, YEAH.
HAPPY TUESDAY, EVERYONE.
OH, MAN, WE HAVE A CLASSIC SHOW
FOR TONIGHT.
WE HAVE BOTH PATTI ANN BROWNE
AND MIKE BAKER ON.
[APPLAUSE]
NOW, PATTI ANN, YOU REMEMBER,
FROM REDEYE.
SHE HAD A WAY WITH WORDS.
>> GOOD EVENING, I AM SITH LORD
DARTH HOTIUS.
AFTER THE DISCUSSION OF THE
RELATIVE SEXINESS OF THE
"FOX & FRIENDS" STAFF,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED I
SAID BRIAN KILMEADE MAKES ME
WANT TO PUKE, I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ADD THAT BRIAN IS PACKED AND
STACKED, BROTHER WANT TO THANK
YOUR MOTHER --
[LAUGHTER]
LIKE PRINCE SAID, YOU ARE A
[BLEEP].
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I THINK SHE ALMOST
HAD CHRIS WALLACE'S JOB.
SHE IS STILL BETTER THAN
CHRIS WALLACE.
AND THEN MIKE BAKER, YOU MAY
REMEMBER HIM FROM "REDEYE" FOR
HIS DEEP INSIGHTS.
>> WHEN I SMOKE SOME WEED THE
FIRST THING I WANT TO EAT IS A
HOT WING SANDWICH.
>> Greg: HE IS ALLOWED TO
CARRY A GUN.
ALL RIGHT, TO THE MONOLOGUE.
SO, IN PREPARATION FOR THE MADE
FOR PRIME TIME SHOWN TRIAL ON
THE JANUARY 6TH RIOTS, HOUSE
DEMS HAVE HIRED A FORMER
ABC NEWS EXECUTIVE JAMES
GHOLSTON TO POLISH UP THEIR
TRUMPED UP TURD.
THEIR GOAL, TAKE OLD BATTERED
EXAGGERATIONS AND REPURPOSED AS
NEW IMPROVED OUTRAGE.
WHAT BEATLEMANIA WAS TO THE FAB
FOUR COME OF THIS HEARING IS TO
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
KEEP IT GOING AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE TO DIFFER FROM BIDEN.
BUT IT IS NOT.
APOLITICAL PARTY SECURES
PRIME TIME REAL ESTATE, ABC,
ONCE EMPLOYED THE PRODUCER AND
IS OWNED BY DISNEY, CAN YOU
FIGHT AND MORE OBVIOUS CASE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN A PARTY AND
THE PRESS?
INTERVIEWS AND PREPRODUCED
VIDEOS AIR SMACK DAB AT
8:00 P.M.
I KNOW, KAT, THAT IS OPPOSITE
"YOUNG SHELDON."
[LAUGHTER]
NEVER SEEN THAT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
BUT IT PROBABLY HAS A MILLION
VIEWERS.
BUT IT IS WORTH IT BECAUSE SOME
IN THE MEDIA THINK JANUARY 6TH
IS BIGGER THAN ALL YOUR
HARDSHIPS COMBINED.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS
PEOPLE ARE JUGGLING, BETWEEN GAS
PRICES AND INFLATION, BABY
FORMULA, ABORTION, AND THE
SHOOTINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING.
THESE LAWMAKERS ARE GOING TO TRY
TO NOW HAVE A NARRATIVE TO FOCUS
THE COUNTRY'S ATTENTION SO THEY
LOOK AT THIS THING, DO NOT TURN
AWAY, AND UNDERSTAND THAT WHILE
ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS ARE
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT, THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR COUNTRY AND
WHAT MAKES OUR COUNTRY FUNCTION
IS THE DEMOCRACY THAT WE HAVE TO
PROTECT.
>> Greg: THEY'VE GOT TO
FORCE-FEED IT.
YOU CAN'T CALL THAT STATE RUN
PROPAGANDA, THEN WHAT IS STATE
RUN PROPAGANDA?
HONESTLY, COULD YOU IMAGINE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY SECURING
PRIME TIME COME BRIDGE FOR A
HEARING ON HUNTER BIDEN AND HOW
THE MEDIA CLAIMED HIS LAPTOP
WAS DISINFORMATION?
THE BIG TECH OVERLORDS ARE NOT
LET YOU DISCUSS IT WITHOUT
SUSPENDING YOUR ACCOUNT.
PROBABLY HAVE TO AIR IT ON
ANIMAL PLANET.
[LAUGHTER]
HOW ABOUT THE BIDEN'S FAMILIES
UKRAINE CONNECTIONS?
THAT WAS A SLOW ROLLING COOL.
YOU WANT MORE?
ACTUAL TERRORISM AND
DESTRUCTION.
ACCUSED OF THROWING A MOLOTOV
COCKTAIL INTO A POLICE CAR IN
NEW YORK AND FACE DOMESTIC
TERRORISM CHARGES IN 30 YEARS IN
JAIL.
SINCE THEY WERE RIOTING ON
BEHALF OF BLM AND TARGETING
COPS --
REMEMBER THAT FOOTAGE?
THE MEDIA DOESN'T.
THEY BURIED THAT, IS ALSO.
YOU HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF
FINDING NONALCOHOLIC BEER IN
KAT'S FRIDGE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AGREED TO.
>> Greg: THIS WEEK, THE
WHITE HOUSE AGREED TO WHAT
JONATHAN TURLEY CALLS A
BREATHTAKING REDUCTION IN THE
TERRORIST CHARGES THAT WILL
LIKELY RESULT IN JUST A FEW
YEARS OF JAIL TIME.
>> REMEMBER, ACCUSED OF HAVING A
PILE OF FIREARMS IN HIS CAR AND
WAS FROM TRYING TO HAND THEM OUT
TO OTHER RIOTERS.
CAUGHT ON CAMERA THROWING BOMBS
AND POSTING ABOUT IT LIKE SHE
JUST THREW A ONE HITTER AGAINST
THE YANKEES.
THEY PLEADED GUILTY LAST YEAR TO
ONE COUNT OF POSSESSING AND
MAKING AN EXPLICIT DEVICE BUT
NOW THEY CAN WITHDRAW THE
EARLIER PLEA AND INSTEAD PLEA TO
CONSPIRING TO ASSEMBLE BOMBS AND
DAMAGE THE PATROL CAR.
IT IS LIKE THEY WERE TOSSING
WATER BALLOONS INSTEAD.
KEEP IN MIND, THE BACKDROP FOR
ALL OF THIS IS TRUMP SUPPORT IS
ROTTING IN JAIL FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF FOR AN UNGUIDED, OFTEN
UNHINGED, TOUR OF THE CAPITOL
BUILDING.
IF THIS KEEPS UP, THESE BLM
BOMBERS WILL BE SENTENCED TO A
ROMANTIC VACATE IN HONOLULU,
THEY CAN MAKE MOLOTOV COCKTAILS
PINEAPPLE AND PAPER UMBRELLAS IN
THEM.
SHOW YOU THE SHARP DIFFERENCE IN
TREATMENT COMPARED TO THE
JANUARY 6TH PROTESTERS, THEY
WERE CALLED A THREAT TO POLICE
AND INDEED SOME MORE, BUT HERE,
TWO SCUM BUCKETS COULD HAVE
BURNED OFFICERS ALIVE AND THEIR
SENTENCES ARE CLOSER TO TAX
FRAUD THAN TERRORISM.
I DOUBT ABC WILL DEVOTE A SINGLE
MINUTE TO THAT.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT
SHOW TRIALS, BUT NO SHOW TRIALS.
THE GUY PRODUCING THE
JANUARY 6TH SPECIAL, GOLDSTEIN,
OR PRESIDED OVER ABC NEWS UP
UNTIL 2021 AND WAS INVOLVED IN
SEVERAL SCANDALS, NOTABLY
JEFFREY EPSTEIN COVER-UP STORY.
REMEMBER THAT VIDEO ABC NEWS
ANCHOR AMY ROBACH CLAIMING THE
NETWORK KILLED HER STORY ON
EPSTEIN AND PRINCE ANDREWS
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND THE LOLITA
EXPRESS?
SORRY, THE STORY WAS NOT KILLED,
THEY JUST HANGED ITSELF IN
ITSELF.
[LAUGHTER]
SEE, THE GUY RUNNING THE JANUARS
YOU HOW THE LEGACY MEDIA WORKS.
IT IS ABOUT TURNING ON AND OFF
THE NEWS FAUCET.
JEFFREY EPSTEIN, TURN THE FAUCET
OFF.
JANUARY 6TH, TURN IT ON AND
LEAVE THE ROOM UNTIL THE HOUSE
IS TOTALLY FLOODED.
AS FOR EVERYTHING ELSE, THE
CRIME WAVE, BORDER CRISIS, YOU
WILL FIND JIMMY HOFFA BEFORE YOU
FIND ANY OF THAT.
INSTEAD, AS THEY SEE FIGHTS
PRESIDENCY IMPLODING, THEY CAN
ONLY DO ONE THING TO SAVE IT:
REVIVE JANUARY 6TH.
THEY GOT THEIR WORK CUT OUT FOR
THEM, BUT THEN AGAIN, DISNEY IS
GREAT AT PRODUCING FICTION.
[APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
WE WOULDN'T HAVE MADE IT VERY
FAR WITHOUT THIS FORMER "REDEYE"
STAR, FORMER FOX NEWS ANCHOR AND
AUTHOR OF THE FANTASTIC NEW BOOK
"WRITE YOUR OWN STORY," HOW I
TOOK CONTROL BY LETTING GO,
PATTI ANN BROWNE.
[APPLAUSE]
HE CAN KILL YOU WITH HIS BARE
HANDS AND ALSO HIS LONG-WINDED
MUMBLING SENTENCES.
FORMER CIA OPERATIVE AND HOST
OF -- ON DISCOVERY SCIENCE
CHANNEL, MIKE BAKER.
[APPLAUSE]
SHE IS LIKE A SWITCHBLADE,
SHARP, DANGEROUS, AND YOU CAN
HIDE HER IN YOUR SOCK.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
AND BEAR TRAPS --
TELEVISION CHAMPION TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
THE NOTORIOUS PAB, HOW ARE YOU
DOING?
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> Greg: GOOD.
CONGRATS ON THE BOOK BEARD THE
FIRST CHAPTER IS
HARROWING BECAUSE IT DETAILS A Y
PROBLEMATIC CHILDBIRTH, I'M
GOING TO READ THE WHOLE THING TO
YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS MY TEASE.
EVERYBODY LIKES A GOOD
CHILDBIRTH STORY AS LONG AS IT
IS A HAPPY ENDING, IF YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN.
>> IT GETS MUCH FUNNIER AFTER
THE FIRST CHAPTER.
VERY DRAMATIC.
>> Greg: I READ THE OTHER
CHAPTER ABOUT "REDEYE" --
>> LOOKING FOR YOUR OWN NAME.
>> Greg: AND THERE WASN'T AN
INDEX, WHICH IS A PROBLEM.
I WOULD CHANGE THAT IN THE PAPER
BACK, JUST TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
ME.
ANYWAY, YOU HAVEN'T TALKED
POLITICS IN AGES, AND I BET YOU
ARE GOING OH, CRAP, I HAVE TO
TALK POLITICS.
>> GET CANCELED.
>> Greg: YOU ARE A HOUSEWIFE.
HOUSEWIFE -- THEY ARE A BUNCH OF
[BLEEP].
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
THEATER?
THE HYPOCRISY, IT IS SO -- WE
KNOW THIS, RIGHT?
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
WAS THAT A QUESTION?
ALMOST.
>> WHAT I LOVE IS THE FACT THAT
TRUMP IS SUPPOSEDLY SAYING HE IS
GOING TO COUNTER PROGRAM --
>> Greg: YES.
>> NOT AWARE IF HE IS DOING THAT
BUT IF HE DOES I WOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED IF IT GOT BETTER
RATINGS THAN THE ACTUAL HEARING.
BUT WE KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO
COME OUT OF THIS HEARING.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF VIDEOS
THAT WE CAN SEE AND PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SEEN THEM SAY THAT THEY
SHOW PEOPLE BEING NOT JUST
ESCORTED IN BUT SOME BEING
INSIDE AGAINST THEIR WILL.
IS IT TRUE?
I DON'T KNOW.
WE CAN SEE THESE VIDEOS.
AND THEY ARE PROMISING NEVER
BEFORE SEEN VIDEOS AT THIS
HEARING.
I THINK THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
THE ONES WE ARE LOOKING FOR.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE THEY ARE DOING A MINI
DOCUMENTARY AND WHENEVER YOU
WATCH A DOCUMENTARY THEY'RE
SHAPING THE NARRATIVE, MIKE,
PEOPLE GO I LOVE DOCUMENTARIES
BUT YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND, THEY
ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN FICTION IN
MANY WAYS BECAUSE YOU ARE
SHAPING THE STORY, MUCH LIKE
YOUR HAIR IS SO METICULOUSLY --
>> I KNOW, RIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: YOUR EXTRA HUNKY
TODAY.
YOU LOOK LIKE HE WALKED OUT OF A
VIAGRA COMMERCIAL.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
JUST SO YOU CAN BE READY WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU PARKED YOUR CLASSIC CHEVELLE
OUTSIDE THE GAS STATION.
>> IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN -- AND
SOME COLOGNE.
DON'T FORGET THE COLOGNE.
AGAINST THE POLO GREEN, I
BELIEVE.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO WATCH THIS?
>> THE DEMOCRATS MADE FUN OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR ALL THOSE
YEARS FOR HOSTING A
REALITY SHOW.
AND NOW, THEY ARE GOING TO HOST
A REALITY SHOW, RIGHT?
THERE IS NO -- EVEN THE
SLIGHTEST EFFORT TO HIDE THIS,
RIGHT?
THEY ARE RECASTING, OR THEY ARE
TRYING TO RECAST THE WHOLE
MIDTERM ELECTION, AS LOOK WITH
THE REPUBLICANS ARE CAPABLE OF
DOING.
BECAUSE IN THEIR MIND, AND WHAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET ACROSS
AND THEY ARE USING SOME VERY
CLEVER MESSAGING, I MEAN IT IS
SORT OF, KIND OF A DICTATOR-LIKE
THING TO DO, BUT THEY ARE USING
SOME VERY CLEVER MESSAGING TO
SAY, LOOK, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS THE SAME AS THE THAT WANDEREL
BUILDING.
THE LAST POINT I WILL MAKE IS
THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
INCESSANTLY, THAT WHAT HAPPENED
ON JANUARY 6TH, WE WERE THIS
CLOSE TO LOSING OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Greg: RIGHT, EXACTLY.
>> IF THAT IS WHAT IT TAKES FOR
THIS COUNTRY TO LOSE OUR
DEMOCRACY, WE DON'T DESERVE THE
REPUBLIC.
>> Greg: IT IS SO TRUE.
IT IS SO TRUE.
IS LIKE -- SOMEBODY MADE A GOOD
POINT, WE SHOULD BAN ALL THE
WEAPONS THAT THEY USED ON
JANUARY 6TH.
[LAUGHTER]
WHICH ONES?
THE ONLY PERSON WHO USED A GUN
WAS THE COP.
CAPITOL HILL COP AGAINST AN
UNARMED PROTESTER.
TYRUS, WOULD YOU DEFINE THIS AS
A SHOW, LIKE A THEATER, A
THEATRICAL SHOW?
>> NO, A SHOW IS USUALLY FILLED
WITH TALENT AND A GOOD IDEA AND
A PLOT --
[LAUGHTER]
THIS IS -- WE HAVE TWO THINGS.
WE HAVE [BLEEP] AND WE HAVE REAL
[BLEEP].
REAL [BLEEP] IS TWO LAWYERS
DECIDED TO GO OUT AND MAKE
COCKTAILS AND BLOW UP POLICE
CARS THAT CAUGHT ON FIRE AND THE
WOKE LEFT GOT INVOLVED AND IS
NOW CONSPIRACY TO COMMIT, WHICH
MEANS THEY HAD AN IDEA OF
MAKING -- AND THE FIRE, NOBODY
WAS IN DANGER, EXCEPT EVERYONE
WITHIN 50 YARDS OF A COP CAR ON
FIRE WHICH COULD HAVE EXPLODED
BECAUSE WHAT DO COP CARS HAVE IN
THEM, BOYS AND GIRLS ON THE WOKE
SIDE?
GASOLINE.
>> Greg: I WAS GOING TO SAY
DOUGHNUTS.
>> SO HAPPY TO HAVE YOU ARE AND
THEN YOU [BLEEP] --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: SEE WHAT I MEAN?
>> THE OTHER SIDE EVERYONE
INVOLVED, WHAT WE KNOW THAT DIDD
NO ONE ON THE RIGHT CAME AND
SAVED THEM.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> MOST OF THEM ARE VERY MAD AT
THE PRESIDENT, SAYING MR. TRUMP
WAS GOING TO PARDON ME, YOU
BROKE THE LAW, I AM NOT DOING
NOTHING FOR YOU.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE.
THE LEFT ARE PROTECTING THEIR
OWN AND DISGUISING IT BY MAKING
IT THEATRICAL -- I AM SURE IT'S
GOING TO BE A LOT LIKE A LOT OF
OTHER TIMES WE HAVE SEEN.
THE ONLY ONE I THINK WILL BE
WATCHING WITH GREAT ANTICIPATION
IS GERALDO BECAUSE THIS WILL GET
THE JIMMY HOFFA THING OFF HIS
BACK ONCE AND FOR ALL.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WADE, DID JIM HOFF
A --
>> AL CAPONE.
>> Greg: SORRY, JIMMY HOFFA IT
IS.
[LAUGHTER]
KAT, I SAID THIS A LONG TIME
AGO -- WHY ARE THEY LOOKING AT
ME?
I SAID THIS A LONG TIME AGO, IF
THE DEMOCRATS THINK YOU ARE
HITLER, WHY WOULDN'T THEY RIGGED
THE ELECTION?
IF YOU HAVE BEEN DOING FOR FIVE
YEARS, CALLING EVERYBODY NAZIS
AND CREATING ALL OF THESE HOAXES
LIKE THE FINE PEOPLE HOAX AND
RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX, WHY
WOULDN'T THEY RIGGED THE
ELECTION?
THAT IS A LEGITIMATE SUSPICION
TO HAVE.
WHY ARE YOU LIKE THAT?
>> BECAUSE I AM FREEZING.
I AM FREEZING EVERY DAY AND NO
ONE CARES.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S HARD TO BE ME.
>> Greg: IT IS HARD TO BE YOU.
>> LIKE, IT'S HARD TO THINK WHEN
I AM SO COLD.
I THINK WHAT I'M GOING TO START
DOING IS GETTING HAND WARMERS
AND TAPING THEM TO MY BODY
UNDERNEATH MY CLOTHES.
>> Greg: THAT IS CALLED THE
BRET BAIER.
>> I'M GOING TO HAVE TO.
>> Greg: KAT, DO YOU WANT MY
JACKET?
>> I WANT 11 JACKETS.
THIS IS LIKE, I DON'T KNOW, I
HAVE TO TALK TO SOMEBODY ABOUT
THIS.
I AM GOING TO DO A DOCUMENTARY
ABOUT THAT.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
THAT WILL GET HIGHER RATINGS.
>> I THINK OBVIOUSLY JANUARY 6TH
WAS A BAD THING.
I ALSO THINK FRAMING A LOT OF
THE STUFF, "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
JANUARY 6TH HEARINGS GIVE
DEMOCRATS A CHANCE TO RECAST
MIDTERM AT MESSAGES.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO SAY THAT OUT LOUD.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> BUT I THINK MORE PEOPLE WOULD
BE MORE CONCERNED OR MORE
INTERESTED IN IT IF THEY HAD
FAITH THAT IT WOULD, YOU KNOW,
BE PRESENTED IN THAT WAY OR IT
WASN'T FOR THAT PURPOSE.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> I DON'T THINK LARGELY WE ARE
THAT DIVIDED ON THIS BEING A BAD
THING.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS
TO THAT, BUT I THINK PEOPLE HAVE
PROBLEMS IN THE PRESENT THEY ARE
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THAN WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH.
>> Greg: I AGREE.
LIKE I DON'T KNOW A SINGLE
RIGHT-WHITE OR REPUBLICAN WHO
HEARD THAT AND DIDN'T GO "THAT
SUCKS," THE FRAMING IS REVERSED,
THEY WERE NOT TRYING TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT, THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE PROTECTING THE
GOVERNMENT FROM A FRAUDULENT
ELECTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT THAT WAY, YOU
GO OH, I SEE.
LIKE AS YOU SAID, THE DOORS WERE
OPENED AND THINGS -- MOSTLY
PEACEFUL.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
WHY DON'T I TAKE THEIR NARRATIVE
FROM THE LEFT.
IT WAS MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
>> THERE WERE SOME THAT DESERVE
TO BE CHARGED --
>> THEY WERE!
>> AND THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WANDERING AROUND
GENUINELY SURPRISED THEY WERE
WANDERING AROUND INSIDE THE
CAPITOL BUILDING.
>> Greg: IT WAS LIKE WHEN I
USED TO BREAK INTO THE
HIGH SCHOOL GYM.
AND I DID.
AND I WON'T TELL Y